today we're going to talk about 10 fake
foods that
you will never buy again once you find
out what i'm going to talk about all
right the first one is fake steak
now what's interesting is um
certain
restaurants caterers
use pieces of meat that have been glued
together with something called meat glue
and that glue is called transglutaminase
now a couple problems with this glue
they have to re-handle the meat so
there's increased risk of adding more
bacteria to the meat and they don't have
to actually tell you
the process
of how they make this glue
originally it was it came from blood
plasma from either a cow or a pig and
then they combine that with certain
things like bacteria and then they
evolved to just fermenting a bacteria to
make this these enzymes to make this
glue but the problem is all of this is
not very transparent you don't really
know how they're making it eating
anywhere where there's bulk filet mignon
you might want to ask them if they use
meat glue all right number two parmesan
cheese
now unfortunately
most parmesan cheese doesn't come from
parma italy which i could just imagine
having that authentic parmesan cheese
from that city is just amazing
but unfortunately
especially in the u.s
you're going to get a different version
of that cheese that is made with
different ingredients it's usually a
mixture of cheap cheeses like cheddar
cheese or powdered mozzarella cheese
with added cellulose and a mold
inhibitor
and what's even worse is the fda makes
it legal to sell this fake parmesan
cheese
and that is because the cellulose is
from natural sources it's from
wood pulp is between
four to twenty percent so that's like
one fifth of the product is wood
so it's definitely a way for companies
to make more money with cheaper
ingredients
all right next one is crab sticks okay
they called it the hot dog of the sea
and i'm talking about imitation crab
another name for that is cerimi and they
take like random fish flesh
or fish leftovers
and of course they add some starch
whether it's from potato
wheat
corn tapioca and they mix that in there
as well with some msg to add as a flavor
enhancer and then they have to add crab
flavoring because it doesn't taste like
crab
and then some protein but that protein
is either an egg white protein soy
protein
and they put some sugar in it sorbitol
and some soy oil or other vegetable oils
then we'll just sprinkle a little sodium
benzonate as a preservative to make it
last longer and of course they have
coloring to make it look like crab but
the next time you see imitation crab now
you know how they make it all right next
on the list is fake tuna and i'm talking
like the pre-cooked canned tuna
or even packaged tuna one company that
did
some investigation into this found that
21
of the companies they found
did not contain actual tuna it was
actually mislabeled so instead of having
tuna
they had some other fish
called escula
escula
uh is known as butter fish or oil fish
and it was banned in japan from
1977 because they said it was too toxic
and they even have a name for it it's
called xlx fish because of the side
effect diarrhea or anal leakage
so if you see your tuna like extremely
white like an opaque white
it's not tuna all right next one on the
list
extra virgin olive oil and i've done a
video just on this topic but
eighty percent
of extra virgin olive oil is not extra
virgin extra virgin means it's processed
very quickly
it's cold pressed it's a much more high
quality process so you have more
antioxidants
and when you consume it it has a
completely different taste and smell it
has a fresh smell and kind of a taste
that
gives you a little tickle in the back of
your throat and so you know it contains
some of the phytonutrients that you need
but it has that fresh grass type taste
that is very different than the fake
stuff which is just bland in fact i
didn't even know what real olive oil
tasted like until i went to italy but as
soon as i found out now i can identify
fake olive oil just by a simple smell
test and about 80 percent of the extra
virgin olive oil is not extra virgin
they add sometimes canola or just a
blend of other oils so
it's rancid it's cooked it's heated it
doesn't have the phytonutrients all
right next one it's maple syrup
much of the maple syrup that you buy
is either made from dark brown sugar or
refined white sugar
with maple syrup
flavoring and artificial colorings
and some of it's even made with high
fructose corn syrup
and of course because these ingredients
don't have the natural antioxidants as a
preservative they have to add
preservatives like
sodium benzoate and ascorbic acid
to prevent this syrup from spoiling next
one on the list is truffle oil truffle
oil comes from a very expensive
mushroom
and so what they do is they found a
flavoring molecule to make some other
materials taste like truffle oil and
they use this in restaurants a lot it's
a way to save money because the the
actual oil is very expensive all right
next one is the powdered instant coffee
some of the blended ingredients
include
cereal
caramel
starch
malt
and figs
in addition instant coffee has something
called acrylamide
a potentially very harmful chemical
in instant coffee a potentially very
harmful
chemical that's created when the beans
are roasted
and instant coffee has more than double
the amount as other types of coffee you
know it can affect the nervous system it
can increase the risk of cancer
if you're consuming it on a regular
basis all right the next one and i have
done a video on this wasabi okay the
vast majority of wasabi in the u.s
is simply a mixture of horseradish
hot mustard and green dye
it doesn't actually come from the wasabi
plant
so it is fake
there's been a report that up to 95
of the wasabi sold is not real wasabi
and i'm talking about all over the world
even in japan
and this is because wasabi is very
difficult to grow and it's extremely
expensive it's like a hundred and sixty
dollars
a kilogram that's at wholesale prices
and when you take fresh wasabi and you
pulverize it you grind up into a paste
it really only lasts for like 15 minutes
and what i mean by lasting is it
basically loses its flavor
but that's not going to happen with
horseradish horseradish is going to last
a lot longer and the last one is
commercial guacamole
just because it says it's guacamole
doesn't even mean it has a lot of
avocado in it unfortunately these
imposters are made with skim milk
vegetable oil water
emulsified egg yolks
and a slew of gums and gels
and it's even thickened with isolated
soy protein
and of course to make it look green they
add food dye and so some of this
commercial guacamole only has like two
percent avocado incredible all right so
the next video i really think you should
watch
is on olive oil there's a lot more to
know about this so i put it up right
here check it out